Hey, I saw your post.
I'm here to help.
Every time you think you have
Cory figured out, you're wrong.
Here Laura Peterson has told
her to abandon her family,
that they're dragging
her down. And here's Cory
in her moment of need saying
"no no no no your
family is all that matters, and
I'm gonna help you find him."
I think it's gonna
create for Bradley
a crisis and it's these
catastrophic events
that really push
people together.
I love you.
Cory's overwhelmed
by the feeling of love for her.
And he's heard this
is what people say
and so it just comes
out of his mouth.
It's authentic and it's so
what we've been craving
since we watched them in
season one and we were like
"kiss her! Kiss her!"
I love the way that
Kerry wrote it.
She's just a wild
and talented genius.
Daniel, I really need
you to come back.
Okay well that's very sweet
and very stupid,
and very much
appreciated but...I quit.
The Morning Show is really
trying to tell the story of what
it's like to be a woman of color
in this level of position
and how Mia is hoping
to make a difference.
And so she's very very focused
on dealing with Daniel's
changes to his own goals.
Can we just be friends and
not talk about work? For once.
How're you holding up?
I love how Kerry did not make
Daniel and Mia one dimensional.
I think Mia is probably
the person who is the
hardest on Daniel this season
and to then actually come
around to really see
how they're able to be
human and vulnerable
with each other at the end.
I hope that people enjoy
that journey this season,
because I definitely
really enjoyed filming it.
You know you called Chip right?
I know.
Chip and Alex their relationship
reaches an amazing place
at the end of this season.
It is at once deeply
unhealthy I think
but there's a purity to it
and a beauty to it because
of how honest they
are with each other.
The network wants
you on the air tonight.
I'm sick.
I know, that's the point.
I knew Alex was
going to get COVID
I just thought, woah
this is gonna be interesting
to try to pull this off.
We did a lot of research
in terms of COVID
and the effects of COVID.
Jen had to really go there.
I'm just hoping I get to go
anywhere Mimi goes
cause she's just my rock.
This show attracts
the most amazing directors.
We are so blessed to have Mimi
as our captain she's
a real visionary.
Okay Alex, we are live in 3
minutes, come on let's do this!
We were inspired by Chris Cuomo
sharing the fact that
he kept working.
He had to show up
and do his show every night.
Or else he was pretty
sure he was gonna die.
Here we go! Here we go! Ready?
Either get on the
Alex Levy train
or just stay at the station.
There's a beautiful
shift in her.
Where you just see her sort of
stop apologizing for who she is
because she's a human being.
We leave her at the
end of season 2 I think,
very much like
the phoenix rising.
And I think we'll
be making bold decisions about
being a person, instead
of a persona.
I'm looking inward
and asking myself,
who is it that I
actually wanna be?
And then I'm looking
in the mirror,
and I'm asking if that's
actually who I am.
For the audience at home
hopefully there's been some
clarity around
what matters to you
and what doesn't.
And what should matter and
what shouldn't.
If we're not trying to draw
lessons from that
then we're not alive to the
world we're in.